hey kid look she's looking at you
see the eye you're high now look here
hold on hello the fish eye oh god
[Music]
welcome back to scrambled except this
time it's done with a difference because
we are in west sumatra on the riverbank
here a little town called bucatini i'm
going to show you how to make the most
amazing scrambled egg stroke omelette
with a beautiful rang dang paste now
this random paste has been cooking
overnight okay it is the essence behind
indonesian cuisine and for me it's all
about the caramelization you start off
with this incredible paste chili garlic
galangal and wild ginger but you add the
beef into it and you almost dry the beef
out and it gets crispy and toasty i've
taken a few spoons of my rang dang paste
out i'm going to put that in not
scrambled eggs but i'm going to turn
that into an amazing omelet
now first off i'm going to start
sort of
frying my onions and garlic so this is
going to be a bit of a sort of spicy
omelet okay
chop chop chop
now
if there's one thing that i've sort of
got up to speed this week in indonesia
and that was the essence and the power
of spice
and the way they use all these spices as
part of their preservation is
extraordinary i was on a boat locally
and out fishing for 24 hours and all
they wanted to eat was rang dang
they have no refrigeration unit but
this rang dang last for days
so
i'm gonna try this in an omelette
and turn the heat
up unscrambled
now slice the shallots garlic
okay
super thin so i caramelize them nicely
garlic in
and i will show you this beautiful
fresh ginger
look at that so
it's almost
completely different to a normal ginger
look at it
so beautiful
so
look how white that is inside so
beautiful
really beautiful and
incredibly fragrant so i'm going to take
a little bit of ginger off there
again
on
and literally
fry that up
now
this ginger is incredibly fragrant
it's going to bring a little bit of
spice
and lightness
to this beautiful omelet
from there chilis
local chillies red chillies i'm going to
leave the seeds in okay
now
again chop seeds
depending how hot you want it
you determine
the length of chilies i like to go about
three or four inches touch of all into
the pan chocolate underneath
and then from there
in with my ingredients
beautiful
get that toasting
nicely
lightly seasoned
salt goes in
i've got a little bit of a kaffir lime
leaf in there as well i'm going to take
that out before i put my eggs in there
and a little touch of
galangal
again i just want to get that nice and
fragrant okay
one nice slice in there
there she goes
make sure you take that out before you
add the eggs it's to make it really nice
and fragrant cook that out
once we start to get a bit of color
on that garlic
shallots
that beautiful wild ginger oh my
goodness me
caramelizes down it's super fragrant and
very very sweet
look at these now these are almost like
our equivalent white bait but they're
dried okay so i'm going to put that in
there
oh
literally chopped up and that's going to
give it the saltiness
inside
again chop them up
and wait and see the flavor these give
off beautiful it's an amazing white
almost like a white bay in she goes
beautiful
now
caramelize that
i want all those flavors coming out
of that
galangal cafe lime leaf right
get the leaves out
get the galangal out
it's done its job
i don't want it too sweet
okay
now
those fish are starting to rehydrate
okay
beautiful
eggs
crack in
these are local duck eggs look at the
color of those yolks so beautiful
amazing
come on this has to be one of the most
spiciest delicious omelets i've ever
made
and
scrambled is all about egg diversity
now from there take a fork lightly whisk
those eggs up
okay
from there and a little touch of
red chili
in
green chili
in
i'm not gonna use any salt in here
because i'm gonna depend on those
wonderful dried little fish
now
mix
the chili in with the eggs i'm frying
the chili the garlic and the onions and
that wild ginger in there
now that i've got that really nice and
toasted look on that beauty caramelise
really nice
okay
in with the eggs
okay mix mix mix
and then we go
beautiful
now
give that a little mix
look how rich that is
that's so good
so now i'm cooking the eggs first before
i set it okay really important
that way
you get this nice even distribution of
all those spices the smell
is beautiful okay
once the eggs are two-thirds of the way
through and cooked
i'm gonna start flattening it okay
before i start baking it i'll explain
why so i get that nice fold
on my eggs
again whisk that round
round and round now it's two thirds of
the way there
start flattening out okay so bake
the base
of that
now i need that to bake for one minute
as that's baking underneath okay i'm
gonna get my rang dang paste
now bearing in mind i've had beef in
here and i've got little shards of beef
left so i'm going to put that literally
in
and just start
dotting that around
this is what's going to give this sort
of indonesian flair
of an amazing
beautiful
rang damn omelette now let that rang
dang paste okay
sit on top of those undercooked eggs
and look
what's gonna happen now is that bottom
of the omelette is gonna bake the rang
dang is going to seep through
and the rendang has been finished with
this sort of caramelized coconut oil so
it's got this really nice fragrant dark
rich flavor
right give that a minute
and then i'm going to start just tapping
as i tap that pan it starts to release
the omelette underneath
hopefully the non-stick pan
[Music]
one two three
tilt the pan up and start folding
this beautiful omelette nicely done pull
that over
and then over
as it starts rolling i tip the pan more
so as it just folds and then we get to
the end
hold it there
off
and then up
and there i have
my beautiful
rang dang
omelet
i've never been so excited to cut an
omelette in half look
oh
that
is beautiful
it tastes
delicious
rich
spicy
and authentic
wow
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing scrambled egg dish
and if you missed uncharted trust me you
can watch it on the link below or on the
nat geo app
[Music]